WIL WILLIS: Jeff,
Craig, congratulations.
You both made it through to
the "Forged in Fire" final,
and you're both one step
closer to a check for $10,000.
In the first two
rounds of competition,
you forged a weapon in
your signature style.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges,
where you will forge an
iconic weapon from history--
the war hammer.
Nice.
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER): The
war hammer is a medieval weapon
developed in the 14th century.
They came about
primarily as a response
to advanced armor technology.
By this time, the armorers had
created suits of plate armor
that was so hard and smooth that
swords would bounce off them.
The war hammer could deliver
its full force to the target
and do serious damage without
having to penetrate the armor.
Its steel head with
a spike on one side
had a handle that
varied in length,
but was generally
just long enough to be
wielded with one hand.
The spiked end could
be used for hooking
the target's legs,
reins, or shield,
or used as an
armor-piercing device.
As the use of body
armor declined,
so did the need
for the war hammer.
However, it can still be seen
today in the popular film
trilogy "The Hobbit"
and has lent its name
to the board game "Warhammer."
WIL WILLIS: Good
luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
CRAIG (VOICEOVER): I'm happy
to be here at the home forge.
I'm in my element.
I know what all my tools are.
I know how to use my tools.
So being here at home is
a big advantage for me.
Takes a lot of steel to
make the amount of Damascus
that I'm going to make.
CRAIG: The plan for today
is to get my Damascus made.
I'm going to take the
two dissimilar metals,
I'm going to heat them up in
my forge, get everything hot.
I'm going to flux them,
keep the oxygen out of there
so scales doesn't form.
Then I'm going to
beat them together.
I feel a little nervous right
now making this Damascus.
I can get a bad weld.
If I get a bad weld in it,
everything I've done so far
is-- is ruined.
It's not a serviceable
weapon at that point.
I'd have to scrap
it and start again.
JEFF (VOICEOVER): I'm
halfway through day two,
and I'm getting the horns
on the ram's head now.
I'm bending the horns
down to have, like,
a very organic curve to it.
Oh, [bleep] [bleep]
JEFF: I've run out of oxygen
on my oxyacetylene torch.
I'm not exactly where I
want to be on the horns,
the hammer head.
It's starting to wear on me.
JEFF: I'm just going to have
to come in in the morning,
focus, and hustle, and make
sure I'm doing things right.
Don't make any mistakes.
I don't have any room for that.
[music playing]
All right, I'm ready
to rock and roll.
CRAIG: Yesterday was
a busy day for me.
I got the Damascus
forged for my head,
and I've got it squared to
about the right dimensions.
Hammer head's going to start
taking shape for me today.
The langets are pretty much
going to lock everything in.
[laughs]
That is cool.
CRAIG: I'm looking at these
sharp corners in these slots,
and I know that I'm going
to have a problem with this
if I try to full quench it.
Where I put the langet pockets
in there, that can crack.
It's thinner than
everything else.
I could literally end up
with two pieces of hammer.
I'm going to do a
differential heat treat on it.
I'm going to try to harden
the front and harden the back
and leave the middle soft.
If I crack the hammer
when I quench it,
that could be disastrous for me.
JEFF: Yesterday,
I was able to get
the hammer head finished
with all the detail,
get it quenched.
And today, I'm getting
into the handle.
My plan is to add
some upholstery
rivets down the sides in the
front and back of the handle.
It's going to be a mix
of unique decorative work
and traditional-style
war hammer with the spike
and the hammer head.
Pretty happy with that.
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen, the
war hammer was primarily
a close quarters
weapon, but it was
devastating to anything
it went up against,
which occasionally
was a castle door.
So I'm going to take several
strikes against this oak door
to see how well the pick
on your weapon penetrates.
Craig, you ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
Well, Craig, this really
felt great in my hands.
It's got a nice balance to it.
Your pick, I don't see
any real distortion on it.
The shape of your pick, with
that nice drop hook to the end
of it, really penetrated well.
And you could see when
I got it in that door
how hard it was to remove.
Yeah.
Nicely done.
CRAIG: Appreciate it.
Beautifully executed.
Thank you.
So, Jeff, your turn.
You ready?
Let's smash it.
DAVID BAKER: All right.
[music playing]
So we started losing pieces.
I can tell that they're on
there only decoratively,
so I was able to continue on.
Good thing, head's
still right and tight.
All right.
The way your pick leans
out towards the front
gave a lot of penetration.
I was really able to just
blow parts out of this door.
Mm-hm.
DAVID BAKER: Nicely designed.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Well executed.
Thanks.
Bladesmiths, now it's
time for the kill test.
War hammers have
been known to deliver
piercing blows into armor and
crush the person behind it.
I will deliver strikes
at this ballistic dummy
that's wearing armor.
Then we can see how much
lethal damage your war hammer
can give.
Craig, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Craig, love the
balance of this blade.
No indentations.
Now let's see how much
damage it put on the dummy.
No visible broken bones, but it
definitely did pierce the skin.
Nice.
This will definitely kill.
Nicely done, sir.
Thank you.
Jeff, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Well, Jeff, looks like the
other langet did break off.
But you know what?
This is still very sturdy.
But let's see how much
damage is done internally.
He's got some broken ribs right
here, broken bones throughout.
It went all the way through.
And even through armor,
you pierced the skin
and you caused some
internal damage.
Jeff, your weapon will kill.
Awesome.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
The war hammer was a favorite
on the medieval battlefield.
So I'm going to take
your war hammer,
and to test the
strength and durability,
I'm going to take several
blows against our stone wall
and see how much
of this I can move.
Craig, you're up.
All right, let's do it.
[music playing]
Wow, that-- that
held up really well.
And that's pretty much a
hole I could crawl through.
[laughter]
That'll work.
CRAIG: Perfect.
So the handle, what I do like
is I could swing it one-handed.
But with two hands,
I could generate
a heck of a lot of energy.
Beautiful job.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Jeff, you're up.
Let's knock it down.
[music playing]
It's long.
And when I was swinging, it
was way out in front of me
as opposed to being
close and in control.
It shot some sparks off.
JEFF: Right.
I seen that.
All in all, a
good performance.
Great.
WIL WILLIS: Craig, Jeff,
you were given five days
at your home forge to
fabricate war hammers,
and they both performed very
well in our weapons tests.
But there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Craig, you are the
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Jeff, your weapon
did not make the cut.
Please surrender
your war hammer.
JEFF: I respected
the judges' decision.
If I knew what I knew now, I
would have changed some things.
Craig, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
It was a fun challenge.
Craig, you will also be
receiving a check for $10,000.
I'm just stoked.
It's crazy.
And this experience, it
was a grueling process.
You know, I got to do
something that I really enjoy
and that I'm really
passionate about.
I came here for my son.
I mean, it doesn't get
any better than that.
[music playing]